You got it. What?
Mashallah. You had it already. Look at
this guy. Mashallah. Mashallah.
Mashallah.
Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
Continuing in
Abdi.
He is a scholar, a doctor out of alar
university who specializes in and
hadith. And as we've mentioned before,
this book largely
is based on the work by say
a very well-known and prestigious well
esteemed
scholar and jurist from alar
university. he passed away. He wrote a
rather lengthy book called
very well known and
is truly a more or less a summary and
some parts of are taken word for word
straight out of
forch.
[Silence]
Bkari and Muslim
both report in their authentic
compilations
a narration on the authority of
he narrates that the prophet sallall.aii
alaihi wasallam said indeed in paradise
there is a gate
meaning a gate to paradise one of the
gates of paradise Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala
did not mention explicitly the number of
gates for paradise in the Quran
he mentioned he rather gestured church
or
insinuated
the number of gates that Jenna has.
How many gates does Jahannam have? May
Allah subhana wa ta'ala hopefully we
will never even have to see it. But how
many gates does Jenam have?
Seven gates. And this is in the Quran,
right? Which
right?
Okay.
Allah indicates
in the Quran in a chapter of the Quran
in a verse he eludes
to the number of gates of paradise.
Who is our Lawi of the morning? our
grammarian
who is going to tell us
what verse what chapter this is
anyone
very awkward silence no guesses
a zuma huh let's hear
Huh?
[Silence]
Yes.
Say it loud.
No, you're missing the exact part.
A great scholar of grammar from the 4th
century. He mentions that this wow.
He mentions that this wow here
is a remarkable wow that is only used in
the Arabic language for the number eight
only eight.
Our
local grimarian is today
and that is that Allah subhanaha
he says
the hellfire it has a different wording
the verse right before it he says
meaning that the gates of the hellfire
are opened. You don't even need that
well. The sentence is perfect without
it. But this well in Z is called well.
It is only used in the Arabic language
to articulate the number eight without
actually saying the number eight.
So Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says,
it's as if he said, "And all eight
glorious gates of paradise are opened at
mass entirely, completely in their faces
for them to enter." This well according
to
this well in his book
this well is only found in two places in
the Quran.
It's found in Z and found in
where
that Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala mentions
this well with the number of the people
of the K those young men that are an
example for us. He mentions that they
were seven
and their eighth is their dog. Their
eighth, their dog was the eighth member
amongst them. And he uses this wow
again. So the Quran eludes to the
number eight in these two verses with
respect to the gates the number of the
gates of paradise.
However, in the sunnah the prophet
sallall.aii alaihi wasallam is much more
explicit with mentioning the number
of gates. He tells us in a
in a narration of
that
paradise has eight gates
and for each gate
is a designated group of people.
meaning that there are eight gates and
the scholars have attempted to enumerate
and label these gates exactly. We know
for a fact there's a gate of fasting,
right? Which is this narration here.
there is a gate for jihad, there is a
gate for salah, there is a gate for
obedience of one's parents
etc. different great rights of Islam.
Now what makes it that a person would
enter through one of these gates? A
person is called to enter invited
through one of these gates
because that person was particularly
excellent at that act of worship.
Meaning the people that fast they were
very excellent at fasting. Person may
say how do you become excellent at
fasting? We all fast the same way right?
It fasting is a non-action. It is
refrain. It is the act of refraining
from eating or drinking. Now we all do
that. We're all equal in that, right?
There's not some of us that eat and
drink a little bit and some of us that
eat and drink a little bit more. No,
you're either fasting or you're not. So,
how can a person be excellent at
fasting? It's not speaking about
refraining from eating and drinking.
person is excellent at fasting when he
refrains from
as we've taken before in the narrations
the more a person refrains from
vulgarity from obnoxious behavior from
ignorant behavior from loud and unruly
behavior
the more a person refrains from
sinfulness and timewasting etc. The more
a person becomes excellent at fasting,
we all start fasting at the same time in
the morning. And as we go through our
day, some of us remain at 100%.
Some of us go down to 90, 80, 75. What
do I mean by that? Meaning in our
reward, some of us will have 100% of
their reward. Some of us will deplete
our fast with engaging in these
prohibited acts in sinfulness. And the
more a person does that, the more their
reward for fasting depletes until
there's no more reward. There is zero
reward. The prophet sallallah.aii alaihi
wasallam tells us
he said there are some who fast
and the only thing they achieve by
fasting is hunger that's all they get
out of it no reward they just did this
physical exercise of making themselves
hungry and then breaking their fast
that's it Why? Because they continued to
deplete and deplete and allow a shaitan
to pick at the chinks in his armor until
there was nothing left of it.
Technically, he fasted.
His ruling is not to repeat the fast. We
wouldn't say repeat your fast, but
there's no reward there. The same thing
with salah. If a person makes a perfect
salah but doesn't have any doesn't have
any focus doesn't have his heart is
not there his heart is elsewhere and his
body is there the prophet sallallah.aii
alaihi wasallam tells us that some
people have 10 out of 10 of their salah.
Others nine out of 10, others eight out
of 10, others seven, six, five, four,
three, two. Some people make salah.
There's no reward at all. Why? Because
that salah was compromised. The spirit
of the prayer was compromised. The
spirit of fasting was compromised.
So the people that are invited through
this gate of paradise,
these are the people who were excellent
at fasting.
They were very good at it. And you know,
people are fingers on a hand.
They're not all the same. Different
different, you know, how we say in
America, different strokes for different
folks, right? Some people are very
excellent at fasting. Some people are
very excellent at knowledge. Some people
are very excellent at jihad. Some
they're just good at it. They it.
They don't get tired doing it. They
enjoy it. They embrace it. Right? And
some people are good at all of those
things. What who's who's a companion who
is invited from every one of those
gates?
Abu Bakr Sadik. Can you imagine
Abu Bakr
there? There's gatekeepers and there's
the angels there that are waiting to
serve the people of per they're wait
they were created just for that
Allah says young handsome
men who were created and they are
eternal young men who were created just
to serve the people of paradise. If you
saw them from a distance, you would
mistake them for scattered pearls.
This is the description Allah gives us
of the servants of paradise. Imagine
these servants are competing with each
other to see which one of them can get
Abu Bakr Sadik to enter through his
door. They're all invited. Come over
here. Forget that one. Come over here.
Come through this door. Come through
this door. Abu Bakr is invited through
all eight gates of paradise.
This gate is called
in the Arabic language is taken from
is to quench one's thirst.
which is on the same it's it's
structured in the same way that the that
the name of Allah is structured alman
means that the gate that is eternally
quenching of the thirst of those who
enter through it is called this gate
meaning that Whoever enters through this
gate will never
have an experience of thirst again
eternally
forever.
This person will never taste thirst
again. We will continue this narration
[Arabic recitation]
[Silence]
I was I was confusing you